EXPEENT.
MOST AMECA WANT HIM OR
DONALD TMP
TO AGAIN.
WELCOME TO OUR HD AROUND THE
TZER.
YOU'RE IN THE SITUATION.
OUTTHE
FIRST OF ALL, PERHAPS INDEEDPRIL
MAOT BEEN CKOUO BE EVACUATED A
NGO GO OUTVER LAND.
HE FEW EVACUATED TO D ATT IN DJ.
INVOLVING SPECIAL FORCES FRO
ACROSS THE W IS UNDER WA A FOCUE
R FAMILIES
THE HORROR OF S NEW
CIVIL WAR.
>> MY FIRST PRIOTYE OF OUDETERI
SECURITYONS IN KHARTOUM
SE AN
KEEPING OUR TEAM THERE ATIMEr: 0
ICRSND'RE ENGULFED IN MAYHEM AMI
, N
VEE KIND O
AMERICANIT
>> FRANCE S ND
500 PEOPLETHS. LESS THAVWF
ReporteUSE THE MO
AI A MILITARY HUB.
>> DO YOU'RE AT A KIND
D OF TE A STORM>> EXACTLYLY
WER AIRPORTS, WE CAN
MANAGE AHE
THE TRIES, BECOMING CENTER
BYFOREIGNERSROATION
WO GIGANTIC OPERATIO
THE SORT SEEN INUL'S
AN UNLIKELY PROSPECT.
>> I WROTE AR TOHE
BEJU EMUT.
IT SEEMS LIKE E'S SIMPLY NO CAR
AMERICAN SUDANESE CITIRRENTLY I
orr: WITH PRISON
EMPTYING AND VIOLESP
MUCHS ON PEACE
COURSE, POTENTIALLY  PROEC MAY
ST IMP THEANNOUNMESE-FIRE,
BUREMEMBS PPED CEASE-FIRE OVER
THE CEE ENOF
N ATIDE WERENORESPECE WERECH AN.
COUNTRY,VE GOT, FOR EXAMPLE,AND
GER
A BIVER
LAND TO PORT.
THE NUMBERS THAT CAN  AT WITHOU
SECURE AIRPORT AT LEAST ARE VE
MI
>> SAM KEYN NEARBY DJIBOUTI,
MUCH.
>>> LET'S TO THE PENT
CNN'EAD OF THIS NEWLY ANNOUNCED
OF AMERICANS WEMAIN IN
SUDAN.
EARLIER.
WHU NING?
OLF, THE
SURVEILLANCE UIN TERMS OF
D AR SUDAN T
HE OTHE GROUND.
HA MONITOR THE LAND ROUT THE COY
TRYING TO GET TO PORD
GET ON A
NO SUDAN ENDG  SHI
AND ONADED THAT WARIGHT
NOW.
WOULD GIVE AOPTION FOR
ANON D TRANSPORTHEM TANOTHER M E
SETATE AONID THERE WERE
IVE EFFORTS TO GET TNCE-FIRE.
NOW IT'S THE CRITICAL SITUATION
O MONITORING TSEE IFT LDS.NEAR L
ADVISER JAKE SULLIN
EARLIER IN THE DAY.
>> WE ARE ACTIVE
THE OFN
AS THE STATE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
UR D
ADVISO W AMERICAN
CITIZEO SUDAN.BUT ANTRY STEN HE
EVACUATIONHEE.IT IT THT ES
DIPLOMATIC STAFF AND FMEMBERS AE
SEVERAL HUNDRED U.S. CITIZENS
>> OREN LIEBERMANN AT THTHD AND
PENTAGON, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.U.
SECRETARY OF, FORMEREON PA
YOU SOH FOR JOIN
USSECRETARY BLINKEN SAYSWANEFIR.
IS THERE ANY INDICATION THAT TH
THISSE-FIRE WILL HOLD?
>> WELL, IT'S A Y
DEN IN
SUN.
KILLED, D OVER 400
AN ON.
I'GLY WEREA I THIN IMPORTANT, O
OTU.S. CITIZENS THERE IN
WE OUGHT TO TRY TO ME USE OF
THE SESY TO DEVELOP
ROUTES OF DEPARTSOO LEAVE THE C
DEPE M.
E U.S. SAYS IT'S
FATA THE WORD TH- AS AMERICANSR
. LIRO U.SCITIZENS
E STILL IN SUDAN WN THE ND?
>> IT'RY DIFFICULT.OUSLY IT'S D
LAE
EVACUATI.ED THAT LESSON I
AND WHAT HAPD THERE. TO BE
NTE
LEA CIVIL HE SAME TIME THINKE D
SUR ERE THEYTHEM
COULD LEAVE THCOUNTR I THINK
THAT WOU B IO >> VERY IMPORTANT
MR. SECRETARY,L TO SEEING SIGNOT
AH THE OUTBREAK OF THE
SUDAN, HAVE RECEIVED
ANT WARNING TO GET OUT
ULTIMA CE TO THAPOINT. ACTEDEARH
I DO T THAT VI  NOTIFICATION AS
POSSIBLE WHEN THER A
DANGEROUS SITUATN
TO ERUPT I IMPORTANT.HER WE HAVN
N'I DO THINKE NOW VESPONSIBITY-
PROTEC DO   DRONES, INTELLIGENC
N PROVIDE IN